Welcome back everyone
This is the way. We got some footage
from episode 7, Episode 8.
the Star Wars?
People always kind of vague
about where the footage comes from.
Like, is this episode seven
or is this from the finale?
there's a bunch of stuff
happening in episode seven.
They have to pay off.
A couple of huge battles
were probably getting a little bit
more Anakin Skywalker, too,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
They were working on Ahsoka Season two
before the strike
started a couple of months ago.
So it sounds like
we will get Ahsoka season two,
but they were kind of vague
about whether or not that would happen
before the Thrawn movie
or after the Thrawn movie.
I think it just depends on when that movie
actually winds up happening.
The plan before the strikes
was to have the Mandalorian season four
be like the last thing before the movie.
Like at the end of the Mandalorian Season
four Thrawn
actual war, his star War
against the New Republic begins.
Right now.
Just expecting them to call that Thrawn
movie Heir to the Empire just to go for
Timothy's on original Thrawn trilogy
because so much of
what they're doing right now
just in the Mandalorian universe,
like all the Mandalorian seasons now,
the Circus Seasons, even the book of Boba
Fett is riffing heavily on story
elements, plot elements, characters
from that original Thrawn trilogy
we're also still doing that Star Wars
giveaway too for Disney plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber.
Just pose all your theories
for the last two episodes on the video.
Careful for spoilers
for everything through episode six
if you haven't seen it yet.
But just starting with
that scene of Thrawn on the hyperspace
ring, the eye of science,
it looks like he's inspecting it.
They're preparing to jump his chimera star
destroyer back to the main galaxy.
Now it's not clear whether or not
they have the rest of the seventh Fleet
if it survived the jump to the other
galaxy or if it was just the Chimera.
during the end of Star Wars
rebels were the space
rebels came to the battle of Atholl
to take Thrawn to the other galaxy.
You notice here at the battle
they have at least three
star destroyers in the purples,
severely damaged each of them.
But when they're actually jumping
into hyperspace,
their tendrils seem
like they're only wrapped around Thrones.
Main Chimera Star destroyer
they almost make it look like the space
wheels totally disabled the other two
star destroyers and only took the chimera
to the other galaxy.
You can see it in the Ahsoka episodes
with all the golden repair parts.
It's meant to go along with the idea
of all the can.
Suki Golden repaired stormtrooper armor
like Thrawn
repaired everything over the past
9 to 10 years in that other galaxy
using this golden metal definitely
makes everything look way cooler.
But in real life, Kinski
literally translates to Golden joinery.
It's part of an ancient
Japanese art of repairing things.
They use this in concept
for Kylo Ren's helmet.
During the rise of Skywalker.
Merrily theory here is that Thrawn
only has the one Chimera star destroyer.
And that kind of explains
why there's only one hyperspace ring,
because it's just big enough to fit inside
the ring.
That'll work a little bit.
Like the prequels era ships like Obi-Wan
Kenobi used a starship with a hyperspace
ring leaders away smaller, involve.
Thrawn is traveling across galaxies.
He'll just be on the main
deck of the hyperspace ring.
My only guess right
now, though, is that they won't show him
actually traveling back to the main galaxy
until the finale.
But I think that's the whole idea.
If it wasn't clear why they announced
the Thrawn movie back in Star Wars
celebration, like, Hey, we're doing this
because Thrawn will make it back.
Ahsoka, Ezra, Sabine, Hera,
The New Republic.
Everybody will take a massive
l in the finale and fail to prevent
his return Episode seven Mostly feels like
it'll be a big battle episode with Ezra
Sabine Ahsoka having a big standoff,
a battle in school in Hati, any of Thrawn
stormtroopers that he sent after them
they're calling them night troopers.
Within the context of the show,
the subtitles call them Night troopers
for a Nightsisters, obviously implying
that some of them are probably already
nice sister zombies like Morag.
Maybe not all of them, but some of them,
the Enoch character
everybody was asking about.
Thorne's main commander is played
by Wes Cheetham from The Expanse.
I don't think he's the nicest zombie,
and that's why they cast such a big actor
for the role.
Otherwise they would just have him
keep the mask on.
So at some point
we'll probably see him take the mask off.
Remember though, Thrawn said his forces
had significantly dwindled
while they were in the other galaxy,
meaning a ton of his troopers had died.
that's what's in all the caskets that
they've been fearing from the nightsister
catacombs.
those look like imperial designed caskets.
when he talked with the Nightsisters
about ferrying the cargo
to the other galaxy in the agreement,
quote unquote,
that he made with the bargain
he made with them.
the idea is basically that
they'll resurrect all of his dead troopers
when they get to the main galaxy.
They'll become his night
troopers, too, with the red markings.
And that's how Thrawn gets his huge
army on short notice
they don't need
a bunch of force sensitive clones
like Moff Gideon wanted to make.
That was his plan for getting a super huge
army on short notice.
But Thrawn still is working
with the Shadow Council
like he needs
the rest of the Remnant Empire factions.
Most of them seem
like they're at least partially on board
with this plan
to resurrect the Emperor too,
which they're calling Project Necromancer.
based on those Mandalorian episodes
with the Shadow Council,
it sounds like they plan on using drones
war against the New Republic to stall
for time, allowing them to complete that
so that they can bring the emperor back.
the thing about that, though,
is that Thrawn doesn't really care
about the Emperor actually coming back.
He's probably just using the other faction
of the Shadow Council to achieve victory.
Like they're just tools to him,
They'll probably reveal more of what
his true grand plan is for the galaxy.
Like he wants to restore the Empire,
but his version of the Empire, like one
that works better, at least in his eyes,
or more efficient version of the Empire.
idea those he doesn't want personal power
for himself.
Like he's not trying to make himself
the emperor because he wants power.
He just wants to run the galaxy in a
more efficient way and protect his people.
That chance
There was also the scene of him
talking about
leaving Baylan Skoll and Shin Hati
in the other galaxy with Ezra.
It's a bit like, let's either kill them
or if we can't, don't worry about it
will just strand them in the other galaxy.
They'll never be able to make it back.
makes it sound like he plans
on killing the rest of those girls too.
So R.I.P. Pergolas.
Hopefully they don't wind up
killing a bunch of them
that'll be a really easy way for Sokka
to take them back to the main galaxy.
It's just a ride
in the mouth of another pearl.
My only guess as to why Ezra wasn't able
to do that in the last nine years
or so is just because he didn't
have a ship available to him like Thrawn
kept him on the run this whole time,
and there weren't available ships
for him to steal
so that he could take them in right
in a prequels mouth himself
But Thrawn isn't meant to be
like a psychopath or anything like that.
Like he doesn't hate different cultures.
Other races.
The way the emperor did is not like he's
trying to wipe out all the force
sensitive people or former Jedi
when he was sizing up Baylan Skoll,
he really only regarded him
as like a dangerous loose end in his plan.
and if there is anything
that Thrawn actually does
hate, it's loose ends in wild cards
that throw his plans off.
If he wants to leave Baylan Skoll
and the other Jedi,
the Dark Jedi characters
in the other galaxy, it's only to remove
variables from his plan
to retake the main galaxy.
Like, Oh,
you could be a wrench in all these plans.
So we're just going to put you off
to the side here in this other galaxy.
that would also include characters
like Luke Skywalker, too.
But he's back in the main galaxy,
so we'll see how they address
that during the Thrawn movie.
Don't worry, I don't think they're going
to completely leave Luke Skywalker
like the other major characters
completely out of that Thrawn movie.
They'll be super
weird to have like a giant Star Wars
movie in this part of the timeline,
and you never ever reference
Luke Skywalker like I don't think
will completely make it through the movie
with at least some references
to what's going on
with the major characters
during this part of the timeline.
but my early hope, though, is that
if they don't do a lot of Luke Skywalker
just in favor
of avoiding a lot of the weird
deepfake uncanny valley stuff,
they'll actually do way more.
And again, Skywalker World
Between Worlds, Force, Ghost stuff,
just him helping out in more in a
can Skywalker in general in present day
in a couple of different ways
that actually be a pretty acceptable
trade off like oh
we don't have a lot of Luke Skywalker
in this Thrawn movie,
but we do have a bunch of and again,
Skywalker, there's supposed to be at least
a few more Anakin Skywalker scenes
in the last couple of episodes of Ahsoka.
I believe we're going to see
a new scene of Anakin
as a hologram in Episode seven.
Maybe it's part of a moment
where Thrawn is sizing up Ahsoka
because he told Morgan Elsbeth,
I want to know everything
about her, about her master.
So that's probably where that comes from.
maybe Thrawn or some of the others wind up
watching holograms of Anakin
Skywalker during the Clone Wars, like, Oh,
this is who were Master was
and then he makes the connection like, Oh,
he knew that Anakin became Darth Vader
and he knew Darth Vader during the rise
of the Empire, Darth Vader had a really
interesting relationship with Thrawn too.
Like, obviously all this came
from a lot of the later material
because he didn't actually see them meet
together in the movies or the series yet.
The whole idea though, is that Thrawn
was part of the regular military, like
he became a grand admiral recently towards
the events of the original trilogy.
Like, that was a relatively new thing.
As the events in Star Wars rebels.
Darth Vader
wasn't actually part of the military.
Like he had a special position
within the power structure of the empire.
He basically was about as powerful
as someone like Grand Moff Tarkin
but if they were in an actual meeting
making actual plans,
most people would defer to Grand Moff
Tarkin and Darth Vader would just have
like, an equal say in the matter.
Generally.
Darth Vader did whatever
he felt like doing on any given day.
Like he kind of commanded the inquisitors,
but he didn't really care
about the inquisitors that much.
They were just pawns to him,
basically to be used The flip
side of that, though, is that
Thrawn was way more traditional military.
sometimes they would cross each other's
paths during different engagements.
And Darth Vader didn't hate Thrawn,
but he didn't necessarily care about him
that much generally Thrawn tried to give
Darth Vader as white a birth as possible,
like he had his own plans
and sometimes Darth Vader's plans
could throw those off the rails.
So he tried to work around
that as much as possible.
generally
he was very curious about all force
sensitive characters, though, and how
he could use that to further his plans.
normally though, he just regarded
Darth Vader is a very powerful person
that he just needed
to keep his eye on the other major battle
that they're hyping up in episode seven,
like I said, is
Ahsoka making it back to the planet,
finding Ezra in Sabine,
maybe all three of them together
or separately having big rematch fights
against Baylan Skoll in Hati.
Thrawn Stormtroopers.
They're supposed to show off some of
Ezra's new force powers and abilities.
He's supposed to be way more powerful,
and it'll explain why he doesn't
need his lightsaber anymore.
And Sabine gets to keep it.
It's basically hers. From now on out.
This might be part of the reason why
they've been doing this whole
Sabine is a terrible Jedi character arc.
Like who? Yeah, just making fun of her
for being the worst Jedi ever.
Because they want to show her
struggling to use even basic Jedi powers
so that when Ezra starts showing off,
he seems way, way more powerful.
the other thing, too,
with Ezra coming back
is that he might become Jason's
Jedi master.
And I think that's what Dave filoni's
setting up for the Jacen character
just in general
in this meant to pay off the idea
that Kanan, Jacen's father,
was Ezra's master.
So now Ezra becomes the master and trains
Kanan's son.
There are a couple.
The big questions
about the Nightsisters just in general.
After last week's episode,
I talked a little bit
about Claudia Black's
nice sister character.
They're calling her clone, though,
and that's based on Greek mythology
and the three Greek fates.
Like all the three nightsisters,
great mothers here
are named after faith in Greek mythology.
that's also why they were talking
about the threads of destiny with Thrawn,
because the Greek fates
saw threads of destiny.
there are a couple of things
they said that
they could not see the threads of,
like a soldier
that might have something to do
with the world between world
What's going on with this weird power
on this planet? Maybe.
And can Skywalker's storyline
maybe this will have something to do
with Baylan Skolls Grand plan.
The power that he feels on the planet
that's calling to him the wants to end
this cycle of order 66 is basically like,
how do you end all war and conflict?
That seems like a pretty big problem
that might have something
to do with the power of the world
between worlds.
We'll learn
at least a little bit more about it
between the last couple of episodes, post
all your theories about that
in the comments below, though.
Like what is Baylan Skoll's actual plan?
How does he plan to stop war
just in general?
my Bullets Episode seven Video will post
next week after they release it
Congratulations, Danny Logo Bay,
you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Star Wars video. Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for my full list
Episode 6 Video and click here
for all my other Ahsoka videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way!